Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, die 2. Männer-Bundesliga, eine weiter unglaublich knappe Liga, das Topspiel direkt vor der Nase. Zwei Trainer-Entlassungen auch noch mit dazu, ein Keller, bis Zeit, also mal wieder für einen Kurzpass. Und den darf heute ich moderieren, nein nicht Max-Jakob Ost, der hat eine ganze Menge um die Ohren. Mit Bundesliga der Männer-der-Frauen-Ligatour, seine Lesetour ja auch noch und so weiter und so fort. Dafür darf ich ihn unterstützen, Nina Pozzel mein Name, genauso auch auf Twitter zu finden. Vielleicht kennt ihr mich ja schon als Gästin hier oder vom Podcast die 45. Da spreche ich jede Woche mit Spielerinnen aus der Bundesliga der Frauen über eben diese Liga oder mit anderen Akteurinnen auch. Und ich habe mir für heute drei Gästinnen eingeladen. Wir werden natürlich auch auf das Spitzenspiel schauen, zwischen Darmstadt 98 und dem Hamburger SV, aber natürlich auch wieder in den Keller, in dem sich die Vereine ja ziemlich auf den Füßen stehen. Und passend zum Samstagabendspiel Darmstadt gegen den HSV sind heute mit dabei Matthias Kneifl, Buchautor, Historiker, Blogger und Podcaster beim Ligien-Podcast Hoch und Weit auf Twitter zu finden, als Ed Kickschuh-Blog. Hi Matthias, schön, dass du da bist.
Ich finde es auch eben so interessant, dass ich glaube am 13. Februar hatte ich noch im Klicker gelesen und das war eben nach der Niederlage gegen Paderborn. Wo die Frage in den Raum gestellt wurde, war es das in Sachen Aufstieg? Und jetzt muss man sich wirklich schon mehr nach unten orientieren und gucken, dass man da nicht mit reinrutscht. Ich finde es auch –Eva-Lotta hast das vollkommen richtig gesagt –absurd, dass man so jungen Spielern so viel aufbürdet. Auch so ein R&B, der ja auch gerade erst 19 Jahre alt ist und der da nicht so unterstützt wird. Was genau das widerspiegelt, Matthias, was du gesagt hast, dass eben nicht mal die Summe der Einzelteile scheint da auf dem Platz zu stehen. Alles sehr, sehr schwierig. Bei Hannover mal gucken, ob sie da weiter mit runterrasseln.
Definitiv. Ich glaube, dann noch einen Einwurf. Dann können wir es auch abbinden. Bei dem Tor jetzt in Regensburg, das war doch, glaube ich, durch Teuchert dieser Distanzschuss, wo dann er auch ansatzweise auf die Fernkurve zugeht und die Arme ausstreckt. Dann denke ich mir so, es war da nicht einzusehen in den Highlights, was die Fans dazu sagen. Aber da würde ich mir glaube ich echt verarscht vorkommen, wenn ich sehe, dass ich mich gegen einen Regensburg in der Form, die ja davor in Nürnberg auch nicht gerade überperformt haben, zu einem unschieden Rätsel und dann ja so signalisiere, hey, war ein schönes Tor, oder?
Auf der anderen Seite könnte das ja auch heißen, dass die Spieler selber wissen, wo sie flehen und eben das schon angenommen haben, hey, wir können uns darüber freuen, dass wir das 1 zu 1 noch gemacht haben überhaupt. Jetzt am Wochenende, wie gesagt, geht es weiter gegen Magdeburg. Das dürfte auch auf jeden Fall ein wichtiges Spiel sein, dass wir da von unten ein bisschen wegbleiben. Dann geht es nach Fürth und dann gegen Rostock. Und dann würde ich mal sagen, kommen wir zu unserer ersten Trainerentlassung hier und springen wieder ein paar Plätze auf dem 13. zu Nürnberg. Das war, wie gesagt, eine von den Trainerentlassungen. Markus Weinziel entlassen, wo ich auch ehrlich gestehen muss, dass ich mich nie so richtig damit abfinden konnte. Das hat sich nicht richtig angefühlt, Markus Weinziel beim 1. FC Nürnberg zu sehen. Jetzt übernimmt Dieter Hecking, der ja auch Sportvorstand ist. War Trainer zuletzt 2019 bis 2020 beim HSV. Also Tanja, du erinnerst dich da vielleicht noch am allerbesten an. Was können wir uns da jetzt erwarten? Wieso kommt der Trainerwechsel jetzt? Und wieso fällt die Wahl auf Hecking?
Warum die Wahl jetzt gerade auf Hecking fällt? Ich glaube, ihm ist nichts Besseres mehr eingefallen. Sie haben ja auch schon den Wechsel von Klaus zu Weinziel weitergemacht. Ich habe irgendwas gelesen, dass Hecking Weinziel auch durchaus massive Vorwürfe gemacht hat, dass er falsch aufgestellt hat und das System nicht so richtig durchschaut hat. Dann macht er das halt selber. Ich bin im Nachhinein sehr froh, dass unser Sportvorstand keine A-Lizenz hat oder keine Trainerlizenz. Das weiß ich nicht. Ich finde das immer etwas schwierig, wenn der Sportvorstand sich dann auf die Bank setzt. Aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass Dieter Hecking da ein bisschen mehr Struktur reinbringt, weil offensichtlich von seinem Kader ist er ja überzeugt.
Da muss man glaube ich tatsächlich aber einhaken, dass es, glaube ich, auch keine komplett freiwillige Entscheidung von Hecking ist. Das große Problem, was der SRFC Nürnberg hat, ist, dass das Geld fehlt. Also Nürnberg ist ja einer dieser Vereine, der auch von Diana Strafe betroffen ist und die ja, wenn man das mal zwischen den Zeilen liest, ja auch tatsächlich noch einen Punkteabzug erwarten. Also warum ja auch man überhaupt, glaube ich, damals von Klaus zu Weinziel gewechselt ist, was ich von Anfang an auch nochmal sagen muss. Weinziel ist dann nicht der erste Trainer, der mir einfällt, der glaube ich auf der Payroll so unfassbar günstig ist. Einfach durch die Erfahrung, die er jetzt, wie er erfolgreich auch immer mitbringt. Er hat einfach unfassbar viele Bundesliga-Jahre hinter sich. Das ist halt nicht so der, sag ich jetzt mal günstigste Trainer, den du dann in dem Moment bekommen kannst. Und ich meine, man hat im Endeffekt dreimal unter ihm in der Liga gewonnen, halt die zwei Pokalspiele. Und es war gegen Düsseldorf. Ich meine, man muss halt dazu sagen, zwei davon gingen eher Aufstiegskandidaten mit Düsseldorf und Paderborn. Aber wir haben eben schon darüber gesprochen, dass dieser Sieg gegen Paderborn in seine Zeit fiel. Also man würde das wahrscheinlich eher noch auf Paderborn schieben als wie gut Nürnberg war. Und das, also Hacking ist halt so dermaßen jetzt im Kreuzfeuer, weil er hat den Kader zusammengestellt. Ich muss immer noch sagen, es geht nicht in meinen Kopf rein, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann, Manuel Winzheimer an einen direkten Ligakonkurrenten zu verleihen. Also erstens bekomme ich dadurch kein Geld rein. Ja, dann guck halt, also so blöd wie es klingt, aber verscherbel den irgendwie nach England oder so. Die zahlen dann immer noch genug Geld im Zweifel. Aber ich mache ja nur ein Minusgeschäft, weil Winzheimer ist jetzt bei meinem direkten Konkurrenten da unten drin und schießt halt die Tore unter anderem. Oder gibt die Assists und ich stehe da und hole mir einen Damien Blum, der sowieso schon eine unfassbare Verletzungshistorie hat und natürlich verletzt er sich und ist raus. Das heißt, ich stehe nicht noch genauso da wie vor der Winterpause. Ich stehe sogar noch schlechter aus, wenn wir meiner Option nach vorne hinausgegangen sind, ich kein Geld habe, um irgendwas daran zu hänkeln. Und der, der dafür verantwortlich ist, steht jetzt auch noch an der Seitenlinie. Also ich weiß nicht und ich meine, da muss man ja natürlich auch sagen, kriege ich mit einem Sportgeschäftsführer als Spieler ein anderes Gespräch als mit dem Trainer. Also was auch eine Erwartungshaltung, weil man weiß ja, im Zweifel ist ja immer als Erstes der Trainer weg, bevor irgendwelche Spieler weggegeben werden. Und Nürnberg-Spieler waren furchtbar mit anzusehen diese Saison. Also die schießen ja auch einfach irgendwie keine Tore. Nach vorne ist es so dünn. Und dann auch noch –ich sage es nochmal –eine Offensivkraft wegzugeben, die ich vor dieser Saison gerade erst geholt habe. Es geht nicht in meinen Kopf rein. Keine Ahnung. Also klar, hat Weinziel dann –ich glaube, dass es jetzt nicht so ungewöhnlich ist, dass er vielleicht nicht früher gehen könnte. Für mich ist dann immer die Frage, ich hatte gerade zwei Monate Pause. Was hätte Weinziel in diesen vier Spielen veranstalten sollen, nachdem er ja ein Spiel gewonnen hat und sie im Pokal auch weitergekommen sind? King von Dona Düsseldorf –das habe ich mich auch vorgefragt.
Warum jetzt dieser Zeitpunkt?
Ja, also in der Retrospective wirkt das alles wirklich merkwürdig. Ich meine, auf Klaus ein Weinziel zu holen, ist auch, glaube ich, schon von der Spielanlage her schwierig. Und wenn ich als Hacking über einige Transferperioden hinweg die Möglichkeit habe, den Kader auszurichten, dann stelle ich mir ja was vor, was Klaus damit anfangen soll und dann hole ich Weinziel. Also das ist wirklich sehr irritierend. Und dieses offensive Trauerspiel ist ja von Eva gerade angeklungen. Das ist tatsächlich auffällig. Und ich meine sogar, dass vor dem Spiel in Heidenheim Weinziel von der Sky-Moderatorin noch gefragt wurde, wie er dann die Strafraumphobie gedenkt zu beheben, weil sie wohl seit ewigen Zeiten schon keinen Tor mehr aus dem Strafraum heraus erzielt haben. Und da kamen eigentlich eher ein paar Platitüden. Aber es zeigt halt auch, dass da der Ansatz im Moment irgendwie schwieriger ist. Und da muss ich schon sagen, Glück auf, Dieter Häckling, keine Ahnung. Da fehlen mir gerade auch so ein paar Ansatzpunkte, wie das sich noch in ein angenehmeres Fahrwasser begeben soll.
Die wenigsten Tore der Liga haben sie tatsächlich erzielt, 17 nur.
Obwohl sie so jemand wie Möller Deli im Kader haben, der ja durchaus auch entstanden ist, eine Chance zu kreieren.
Der ist gerade in seinem richtigen Loch drin.
Ja, die Frage ist ja auch, Torchancen für wen kreieren. Also es tut mir leid, Quattro Trua bringt halt Schnelligkeit mit, hat auch das eine oder andere Tor geschossen, aber er ist definitiv wahrscheinlich nicht so der Zielspieler. Mir fehlt halt, dann muss man Valentini wieder in die Rolle schlüpfen, der vorher eineinhalb Jahre nicht getroffen hat, fliegt dann aber am nächsten Spiel vom Platz für einen Spieler wie Valentini, Summela, dass wir das so sagen müssen, aber Naivität in dieses –also es war halt wirklich, was man ja eigentlich Frustfaul nennt. Ja, aber irgendwie, also man hatte dann, mir tut es auch so jemanden leid wie Winderl, den Teuter, den sie auch verpflichten mussten, weil Martenia verletzt ist, aber auch diese Innenverteidigung. Ich hab einen Jamara, den Tanja bestimmt auch noch sozia beim HSV kennt. Ich hab irgendwie Hübner und Kastrop und da waren Abwehrfehler dabei gegen Heidenheim. Also ich meine, klar kann man gegen Heidenheim verlieren, aber ob man jetzt den roten Teppich im Strafraum ausrollen muss, das ist halt eine andere Frage und das hat für mich dann noch nichts mehr mit System zu tun. Also davon abgesehen, dass ich nicht verstehe, warum Weinzie durchgängig mit dem 4-4-2, mit Doppel-6 gespielt hat, weil es irgendwann halt die Offensive überhaupt nicht anbietet. Aber ja, weiß ich nicht.
Also jeder von den Hörerinnen darf sich ermuntert fühlen, mal die Kicker-App aufzurufen und bei Nürnberg den Kader durchzugehen. Man wird bei kaum einem Zweite-Legisten mehr Spiele unter Sturm aufgelistet sehen. Da sind sicherlich auch junge Spieler mit dabei. Aber es ist ja irgendwie auch eine Unwucht. Und dafür kommt vielleicht wenig bei rum. Und die Verletzten klangen gerade schon an, auch in der Verteidigung. Also da ist natürlich wirklich ein bisschen Bluten müssen. Nicht nur in Martenia, auch mit Handwerker und Wegesser. Und dann der nachverpflichtete Horn, der kommt auch sich nochmal verletzt.
Das ist natürlich Pech, aber alles in allem …Ich finde das auch irgendwie total interessant, dass es ja sowieso schon die Kritik gab, dass der Kader viel zu groß wäre. Und dann holen sie jetzt in der Wintertransferphase auch nochmal wahnsinnig viele neue Leute. Also müssen sie irgendwie auch wegen verletzten. Aber dann haben wir Dani Blum, Benjamin Goller, den ich eigentlich auch für einen sehr guten Fußballer halte. Florian Flick von Schalke ausgeliehen, Janis Horn von Bochum ausgeliehen, Gustavo Puerta von Leverkusen ausgeliehen. Das sind natürlich auch viele Lien. Dann haben wir noch Jermaine Nischalke, Peter Winder-Jensen eben. Und dagegen nur einen Abgang. Aber der dann eben Manuel Winzheimer ist. Anderen direkten Kollegen. Also auch hier ein riesengroßes Fragezeichen. Habt ihr noch unbedingt was, was ihr loswerden wollt zu Nürnberg? Oder wollen wir weitergehen?
Nee, also ganz kurz so mal. Aber noch mal, der dafür verantwortlich ist, steht jetzt an der Seitenlinie. Ich weiß halt als Nürnberg-Fan nicht, wie ich darüber fühlen sollte.
Ist halt seine große Chance vielleicht auch alle irgendwie, um sie falsch zu beweisen?
Ja, aber auch dann hat er ja nicht die Trainer verpflichtet, die mit zu den Spielern passen und vice versa. Also alles, egal wie es jetzt läuft, das ist eine absolute Loose-Loose-Situation für Dieter Hecking.
Ja, aber wie wir festgestellt haben, der Kader ist ja groß genug, um eigentlich alle Systeme zu spielen.
Vielleicht war das sein ultimativer Plan. Was ich ganz witzig finde, ist, dass es jetzt am Wochenende für Nürnberg, also mit Dieter Hecking, an der Seitenlinie gegen Sandhausen geht. Die haben ja auch gerade ihren Trainer entlassen. Als Hecking noch Trainer beim HSV war, ist er damals geflogen nach dem 1-5-Debakel gegen Sandhausen. Da ist also eine Rechnung offen und irgendwie passt alles so zusammen. Das ist irgendwie ganz witzig. Danach, nach Sandhausen, kommt aber eben auch schon der HSV. Danach Braunschweig gegen Winzheimer. Das sind alles irgendwie Spiele, die nicht so ohne sind, sagen wir es mal so. Dann springen wir mal weiter zu Magdeburg, die ja eigentlich ganz gut gestartet waren, sind jetzt auch so über den Strich gerutscht. Gerade so ist ja wirklich alles noch mal irre knapp da unten. Sie sind jetzt aktuell punktgleich mit Braunschweig. Ein Punkt hinter Nürnberg eben. Und die sind auch, ja, ich weiß nicht, für Magdeburg eigentlich ziemlich okay gestartet, würde ich fast sagen. Also eine Niederlage, zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden und ein Sieg gegen Kiel eben. Jetzt zuletzt diese zweite Niederlage eben gegen St. Pauli 1 zu 2. Haben drei Neuzugänge in der Winter-Transferphase noch verzeichnet. Daniel Heber von Rot-Weiß Essen, Maximilian Ullmann von Venezia aus der Serie B ausgeliehen auch. Und Luke Castañas. Ein Abgang. Ömer Bey ist jetzt nach Stuttgart gegangen. Wie findet ihr das so? Wie findet ihr diesen Restart, wenn man es so sagen will, nach der Winterpause von Magdeburg? Was haltet ihr von diesen vier Spielen? Matthias vielleicht?
Da bin ich jetzt fast auf dem falschen Fuß. Ich finde, du hast die Neuverpflichtungen angesprochen, die jetzt zur Winterpause kamen. Sie hatten ja auch schon im Verlauf der Vorrunde nachjustiert. Also Piccini kam, glaube ich, nach dem Saisonbeginn. Ist ein richtig guter auf seiner Position in der Verteidigung. Bochon, glaube ich, kam auch erst nach Saisonbeginn. Der hatte ja in Bochum durchaus auch auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, hat eine Schnelligkeit. Also das zeigte mir, dass Magdeburg schon früh ein paar Zeichen erkannt hat, wo es nochmal nachzujustieren gilt. Und ich finde, die Spiele nach wie vor für einen Aufsteiger sind sich treu geblieben, haben in der 3. Liga schon spielerisch überzeugt. Baris Atik natürlich in erster Linie auf sich aufmerksam gemacht und zumindest bis zum Darmstadt-Spiel haben sie diesen Plan nachverfolgt und sind ihm treu geblieben. Das finde ich wiederum sehr zu begrüßen, dass jemand hinter seinem System steht und dem vertraut und dann noch Spieler hinzuaddiert, die eventuell dann passen könnten. Natürlich sind sie viel zu heimschwache. Ich glaube, 8 Punkte nur zu Hause, das ist natürlich, gerade bei so einem stimmungsvollen Publikum, ja irgendwie auch fast verwunderlich, dass das nicht so ganz aufgeht. Und da muss schon schleunigst ein bisschen mehr bei rumkommen, um die Klasse dann auch schlussendlich zu halten. Ich hoffe auf jeden Fall, dass sie sich trauen, an Tits festzuhalten. Weil dann, ich habe auch die gegen Darmstadt ganz gut gesehen. Die haben dann eben von diesem dämlichen Platz verweist, der für mich keiner war, eben nicht profitiert, sondern der fuhr ihnen in die Parade. Davor war das sehr gefährlich, was die gemacht haben, und auch zu Abschlüssen gekommen. Deshalb will ich hoffen, dass sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen in ihrer Lehre ziehen, aber rechtzeitig die Lehre ziehen, um dann die Kurve zu kriegen oder eben nicht ganz unten reingesogen zu werden. Die zweite Tabellenhälfte ist verdammt eng. Also reicht schon ein Spieltag, um sich auf dem letzten Platz wieder zu finden. Deshalb ja mein Plädoyer und meine Hoffnung, dass das fruchtet, was da so angelegt ist.
Ich finde es auch ganz unabhängig von den anderen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, aber Magdeburg, den würde ich auch irgendwie echt wünschen, dass sie so noch mit drin bleiben in der zweiten Liga, weil ich finde, es macht auch echt Spaß, den so zuzugucken. Und irgendwie finde ich es schön, wenn sie sich ja etablieren können. Baris Atek, muss ich auch nochmal sagen, dieser Distanztreffer gegen St. Pauli zum 1 zu 0. Also sehr schön, bin ein großer Fan von. Eva, ich weiß nicht, hatte ich das richtig gesehen, dass du was sagen wolltest auch oder?
Ja, ich finde halt bei Magdeburg das größte Problem ist, dass die sich selber im Weg stehen. Also, ich meine, wenn wir uns jetzt irgendwie mal so vielleicht mehr als nur die letzten, also die vier Spiele in 2023, ich meine, ich habe sie ja natürlich auch gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Matthias, du hast das Spiel gerade gegen Darmstadt erwähnt. Auch im Spiel gegen Bielefeld. Die waren eigentlich so schlecht. Also, die hatten, glaube ich, auch mehr Schüsse aus Tor, waren offensiv, auch nicht unattraktiv. Aber, also, und gegen Aminia Bielefeld zu diesem Zeitpunkt, 3-1 zu verlieren, gegen einen Mitkandidaten da unten, gegen einen Abstieg und dem halt wirklich mehr oder weniger den Sieg zu schenken, weil man viel zu einfache Fehler macht, weil man zum Teil nicht rausrückt, weil man irgendwie einen Spiel auch irgendwann verschenkt. Also das fand ich so krass zuletzt gegen St. Pauli. Es gibt wenig, was man bei St. Pauli nicht macht. Also gegen St. Pauli sollte man eine Sache vor allem nicht machen, und das ist bei Standards nicht vernünftig aufpassen. Weil man weiß immer gerade durch Lea Pakarada, der ist in, sagen wir mal, acht von zehn Spielen sehr, sehr gut drauf, auch wenn der Rest jetzt Teamnissing macht und dann steht halt irgendwie Jackson Eulwaer, dass auch nicht zum ersten Mal diese Saison passiert ist. Komplett frei im 16er kann da einnicken und dann denkst du dir, ja okay, geht es halt 1-1 aus. Und dann aber irgendwie dann nochmal pseudomäßig auf Abseits zu stellen in dieser Szene mit Medici. Ich meine, das war ein super Ball von Hardel, glaube ich. Aber dann irgendwie da noch mal dieses Gegentor zu fangen, das meine ich mit, die stehen sich halt selber auf den Füßen irgendwie. Ich finde auch den Heber, Daniel Heber war eine unfassbar gute Ergänzung. Der hat, glaube ich, gegen Düsseldorf dreimal irgendwie auf der Linie geklärt. Du hast mit El-Fadli jemanden, der eigentlich in der Verteidigung spielt, aber durchaus auch jetzt irgendwie sein offensives Blut entdeckt hat. Aber auch das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf. Düsseldorf war nicht gut. Dieses Spiel war nicht gut. Und Magdeburg hätte da durchaus einen Punkt verdient gehabt. Aber sie stehen sich da irgendwie selber auch im Weg. Und es gibt irgendwie Flipper-Tore hier und da. Und man verschenkt die letzten 15 Minuten. Man hört einfach auf, Fußball zu spielen, lässt Düsseldorf rankommen, irgendwie gefühlt 20 Torschüsse noch abgeben. Und dann kommt natürlich dazu –und ich glaube, viele von uns haben es irgendwie gesehen –nach diesem 1-1 gegen Karlsruhe, du denkst, ey, Magdeburg ist immer noch Aufsteiger. Die haben vor der Saison die Hälfte ihres Karlsruhes an Paderborn verloren gefühlt. Spielen da 1-1, all good. Und dann gibt es irgendwie diese Ansprache der Fans, wo man die Leistung kritisiert. Und dann gewinnt man die Woche drauf gegen Kiel, wo man aber nochmal sagen muss, warum weiß niemand, weil Kiel darf dieses Spiel in tausend Jahren nicht verlieren, wo ich mir denke, was mache ich damit? Gut, nutze ich die ganze Stunde, muss ich gegen einen sehr, sehr guten St. Pauli, die extrem gut in das neue Jahr unter Hürzler gestartet sind, reingehen, spiele vielleicht 45 Minuten Fußball und höre dann aber auch auf, wo ich mir als Fans denke, da muss ich tatsächlich mal sagen, nicht nur wirklich auf die Ergebnisse gucken, sondern was wird leistungstechnisch geboten, und das darf sich Magdeburg erlauben, im Gegensatz zu, ich weiß jetzt im Hannover 96, wo man sagen muss, wir haben zumindest noch 1-1 gespielt, da steht eine Mannschaft auf dem Platz, wo ich mich dann frage, irgendwie passt es dann für mich auch erwartungshaltungstechnisch, der Fans nicht zusammen, ich möchte niemanden nicht Fans reinreden, wie sie mit ihrer Mannschaft umzugehen haben, aber es hat mich schon stark verwundert irgendwie, weil ich das einfach das falsche Zeichen zu diesem Zeitpunkt finde. Gerade wenn du zu Hause absolute Probleme hast, ich habe es angesprochen, weiß ich nicht, ob das der richtige Weg ist, und indirekt hast du ja gegen St. Pauli gesehen, geholfen hat es nicht, zu Hause da dann irgendwie zu bestehen.
Ich muss aber auch noch mal kurz dazu sagen, ich kenne ja Christian Titz jetzt auch schon als HSV-Trainer, wir reden ja auch nicht, das waren ja alle irgendwann mal bei uns. Ich mag den total gerne, der ist zwar mit uns abgestiegen, aber er hat sozusagen das Volksparkstadion gerettet, weil durch seine positive Art ist der Abstieg halt nicht so komplett in die Binsen gegangen. Aber sein Spielsystem ist halt extrem offensiv und defensiv kann er nicht. Das sieht man jetzt halt auch bei Magdeburg. Als Aufsteiger ist das echt gefährlich, was er da spielen lässt.
Macht halt Spaß, aber ist gefährlich, absolut. Am Wochenende geht es jetzt gegen Hannover. Das wird ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Spiel, aber ich glaube trotzdem auch, gegen wen, wenn nicht gegen Hannover aktuell, da irgendwie mal ein paar Punkte holen. Danach jetzt gegen Lautern und Paderborn. Alles nicht so einfach. Da ist also auch nochmal ordentlich Gefahr da, dass es auch nochmal ganz tief runtergeht. So sah es ja eben auch bei Regensburg aus, wenn wir jetzt mal weitergehen und die Arminia überspringen. Weil, wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind, da ist schon eigentlich genug gesagt und viel mehr Neues außer Frust, sage ich mal. Da kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht sehr weit bei rum. Bei Regensburg finde ich es sehr schön, sich bei Transfermarkt mal diesen Grafen anzugucken, wie der Verlauf der Tabellenverlauf aussieht. Das ist eine sehr schöne Kurve. Erst so ein bisschen nach oben und dann sehr rund nach unten und jetzt wieder nach oben. So ein kleines bisschen der Ausflug ans Tabellenende als Schlusslicht war wirklich nur sehr kurz. Auch weil es da noch ein anderes Team gibt, dass da noch schlechter am Start ist. Die letzten vier Spiele im neuen Jahr waren auch nicht gut. Drei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden, dieses Unentschieden 1 zu 1 gegen Hannover davor, gegen Nürnberg, Bielefeld und Darmstadt verloren. Das sieht, wie gesagt, echt nicht gut aus. Gemeinsam mit Aminia ein Punkt hinter Magdeburg und Braunschweig. Die Passquote, das fand ich auch sehr bezeichnend. Wenn wir mal mit den Statistiken losgehen, liegt im Schnitt bei rund 76 Prozent. Das sind 75,6 Prozent, glaube ich. Das ist ein drittschlechteste. Das sieht man auch sehr gut auf dem Platz. Matthias, deine Lilien haben ja eben dieses Auftaktspiel nach der Winterpause gegen Regensburg gemacht. Wieso sind die noch mal so krass abgestürzt? Die waren ja davor, vor dieser Winterpause, noch nicht so tief drin.
Sie haben auch am Anfang den Eindruck erweckt, als hätten sie einen Plan. Sie sind schon ziemlich gallig rangegangen. Das kennt man eigentlich als Gegner von Regensburgern Teams, dass die schon eine gewisse Körperlichkeit auf den Platz bringen und damit auch schnell mal anderen Teams den Schneid abkaufen. So ist zumindest bei mir Regensburg gerne mal in der Schublade. Die ersten zehn Minuten sahen auch wirklich gut aus, aber dann haben sie sich durch zwei Fehler aus dem Spiel genommen. Einmal haben sie einen neuen Torwart, ihr junger Torwart, Keeper Jonas Urwig aus Köln, dem sie gleich das Vertrauen geschenkt haben. Der ist quasi zwischen die Pfosten gewandert, spielt zentral raus. Ich glaube, ich komme jetzt gerade nicht darauf, wer den Fehler gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall wollte der Ballabnehmer dann irgendwie einen Lillenspieler stehen lassen, aber das war eine denkbar schlechte Idee. Mirlem ist dazwischen gegangen. Dann war es durch Manu 1-0 und dann noch ein Platzverweis durch Kennedy, glaube ich, wenig später. Das Spiel war damit schon die falschen Bahnen aus Regensburgers Sicht geleitet und dann durch einen 2-0 noch vor der Pause gegessen. Die zweite Halbzeit hätte man sich sparen können. Da war Regensburg sich selbst im Weg gestanden und hat es nicht geschafft –klein unterzahll ist es schwer –aber irgendwie noch Akzente zu setzen in dem Spiel. Das hat mich dann ein bisschen überrascht. Bei Regensburg hatte ich doch von der Mentalität anders kennengelernt. Im Kicker hatte ich zuletzt mal gelesen, die haben ihren Sportverstand damals nach Köln abgegeben vor mittlerweile 15, 16 Monaten, glaube ich. Seither ist die Punkt-Schnittquote von Regensburg gar nicht so gut, die sich um den einen Punkt oder sogar noch weniger herumgruppiert. Da wurde dann so ein bisschen hergeleitet, der Abgang tut schon weh, weil der war mehr als jemand, der in der Chefletage sitzt, sondern der schon auch für den Club viel beleuchtet hat. Regensburg ist ja kein großer Standort. Wie in Darmstadt auch, kennt man kurze Wege und spielt wahrscheinlich auch eine andere Rolle als jetzt beim VfB oder beim HSV oder bei sonst jemandem. Da wurde diese Personalie einfach erwähnt. Das fand ich dann in der Quote ganz interessant, dass das vom Punkt-Schnitt deutlich nach unten ging. Ich bin gespannt, wo es jetzt mit Ihnen weitergeht. Ich kann es jetzt nicht so sehr einordnen. Es ist jetzt für meine Begriffe kein unruhiger Standort. Ich glaube, da weiß man auch, welche Qualitäten man auf den Platz bringen muss. Gegen Nürnberg war es wohl sehr, sehr mau, was sie gezeigt haben. Da hingegen ging Hannover jetzt wieder in eine richtige Reaktion gezeigt. Sing kommt jetzt zurück, der vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen was spielerisches oder in kreativem Sinne, was Torchancen anbetrifft, beisteuern kann. Vielleicht fehlen Ihnen aber auch so Spieler, die in der Panne gekommen sind, wie ein Besuchkov, der in Regensburg schon eine gute Rolle gespielt hat. Oder auch Weckesser, der eine Wahnsinns-Physis reingebracht hat und auch schon Gegenspielern wehtun konnte, ohne jetzt überziehen zu müssen. Aber vielleicht sind es auch so ein paar kleine Schräubchen. Aber ich traue denen zu, so in gallischer Dorfmanier doch noch irgendwie da unten sich zu behaupten.
Wie gesagt, es ist ja auch super schwierig, einfach weil da alles so eng ist. Jonas Urbig, du hattest es gesagt von Köln ausgeliehen. Der ist gerade 19 Jahre alt und das finde ich auch super spannend. Von Stojanovic zu Kirchbaum zu Urbig, von 29 zu 35 zu 19. Irgendwie sehr spannend. Eva, du wolltest auch noch was sagen.
Ja, ich finde halt irgendwie bei Regensburg ist bei mir so ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie ja letztes Jahr auch gegen Ende der Saison durchaus noch da unten reingeraten sind. Und eigentlich damals nur wegen ihrer, glaube ich, sechs Spiele am Anfang der Saison, wo sie ja zwischenzeitlich auch an der Tabellenspitze standen, eben, man muss das glaube ich so sagen, nicht abgestiegen sind. Und was für mich halt eher das Problem war, ist, dass ich im Sommer keine richtige Reaktion darauf gesehen habe. Also ich fand eigentlich Stojanovic als Torhüter keine schlechte Wahl, weil Meier ja nun mal zu Borussia Dortmund gegangen ist. Hab ihn jetzt aber auch irgendwie schon wieder durch einen, wie schon gesagt, 19-Jährigen ersetzt, wo wir wieder über das Thema Druck bei jungen Spielern sprechen.
Sieben Gegentore in vier Spielen helfen da auch nicht unbedingt?
Nee, und dann hast du halt auch, weiß ich nicht, fehlt mir da auch irgendwie, da fehlen mir bis heute die klaren Ersatzspieler. Du hast jemanden wie Prinz Jose Owusu geholt, der glaube ich seine ersten Zweitliga-Tore jetzt mal bei Regensburg geschossen hat, der aber vorher bei Bielefeld und Paderborn nicht gerade Top Go-Getter geschrien hat. Also von außen, auch da der einzige, den ich vielleicht mal so ein bisschen positiver auch hervorheben würde, ist jemand wie, ja, Leute wie Jan Elvedi, die da im Defensivwerk so ein bisschen versuchen, die Dinge zu ordnen. Elvedi hat ja auch unter anderem gegen Bielefeld dann da sein erstes Tor geschossen, fast ein Doppelpack. Sabrit Singh ist halt wirklich für mich ein merkwürdiger Spieler. Ich meine, er sollte, glaube ich, ja auch zu Werder kommen, hat da den Medizintest nicht bestanden. Und jetzt sollte er von Bayerns Zweiter an –eigentlich ist er ja seit Anfang der Saison bei Regensburg –aber er durfte, hatte keine Spielberechtigung, weil irgendwelche Unterlagen vergessen wurden einzureichen. Wo man dann natürlich auch sagen muss, auch das geht dann Richtung Geschäftsführersport. Was du angesprochen hast, Nina, ist dann natürlich auch die Frage, hilft alles auch nicht, diese Position zu stärken? Natürlich mit Andreas Eivers, der jetzt sechs Tore hat, schreit jetzt auch nicht irgendwie. Ja, weiß ich nicht, Top-Go-Score auch hier.
Und der auch Hannover aus dem Spiel hätte nehmen können am Wochenende mit dem Elfmeter.
Ja, und dann ja eher noch dafür sorgt, dass Hannover überhaupt zurückkommt, weil er den Ball nicht vernünftig klärt. Und ich habe sie ja sogar live im Stadion gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Ich meine, man muss auch sagen, auch ein bisschen unglücklich da. Man könnte auch da über einen Elfmeter eventuell diskutieren gegen Mowusu, der dann ja auch jetzt erstmal raus ist, mit einer Kopfverletzung in die Richtung. Aber auch da hat man in der zweiten Hälfte Bielefeld so unnötig am Ende kommen lassen. Das war in der Verteidigung nicht zweitligereif. Also zweimal sich so ein Tor zu fangen, vor allem das zweite Tor von Klos, wo der ungefähr von der Strafraumkante diesen Ball reinköpfen kann, ohne dass irgendjemand dagegen was unternimmt, nach einem langen Ball, der von Huck auf eine andere Seite reinkommt. Das darf den nicht passieren. Und für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt fast eher überreif, dass Regensburg in diesem Abstiegskampf ist, weil sie eben letztes Jahr da schon waren. Da dachte man kurz am Anfang der Saison haben sie gegen Darmstadt gewonnen, sie haben gegen Bielefeld gewonnen, aber auch gerade gegen Bielefeld. Das war schon kein überzeugendes Spiel von ihnen. Da hat es halt einfach zu dem Zeitpunkt sowieso gereicht, wenn die Gegner von Bielefeld maximal mit 70 Prozent angereist sind. Aber für mich ist es ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht überraschend, dass sie da unten drin sind. Und ich frage mich, klar, wir freuen uns alle, wenn Mannschaften auch mal länger an einem Trainer festhalten. Aber bei Siljanović sehe ich halt genau die gleichen Mechanismen, die greifen wie letztes Jahr, wo ich mich dann halt frage, naja, also entweder ihr habt keine höhere Erwartungshaltung und sagt, da gehören wir halt irgendwie hin, den Abschießkampf der 2. Liga. Oder ich muss halt irgendwann mal sagen, sind wir ehrlich? Wir nehmen seit einem Jahr keinerlei Entwicklung in dem Sinne. Wir müssen wirklich sagen, das sind keine Ausrutscher, sondern das, was nach oben geht, sind positive Ausrutscher. Und da frage ich mich halt tatsächlich, wie lange gucken sie sich das noch an? Jetzt sagen sie wieder, ne, mehr ist fest bei uns im Sattel. Weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube halt schon, dass du mit dem Kader ein bisschen mehr machen könntest. Aber jetzt natürlich keinen einstelligen Tabellenplatz. Aber ich finde es schon merkwürdig, dass da immer noch keine Reaktion gekommen ist.
Aber wenn ich mir so mal den Kader beim Kicker angucke, dann sehe ich, dass da fünf Mittelfeldspieler sind und zehn Stürmer. Das nenne ich einen unausgewogenen Kader. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer da jetzt hauptverantwortlich ist, ob ich den Begovic sagen kann, ich will die Spieler, die Spieler, die Spieler oder ob das halt tatsächlich von Tobias Werner als Sportchef oder was auch immer er da ist, so verantwortlich ist.
Wobei, ich finde auch immer beim Kicker, manchmal nehmen die damit unter den Schwung.
Sie sind da manchmal etwas komisch, ja.
Ja, das ist manchmal so ein bisschen. Aber im Grunde, ja, hast du recht. Ich fand auch noch weitere Statistiken, die ich noch anmerken wollte. Wie gesagt, die Passquote dritt schlecht, das da haben wir schon. Drittmeiste Gegentore und die drittwenigsten Tore selbst geschossen. Das spricht auch alles dafür, dass das eher schlecht wird. Und Eva, du meinst, es wird langsam Zeit für einen Trainerwechsel da?
Ja, also ich meine, davon abgesehen, oder dass man drüber nachdenkt zumindest mal, muss man auch sagen, wer es soll kommen. Also, ich meine, wir sprechen gleich über einen der Trainer, der reinkommt, wo ich mich tatsächlich frage, das war der Trainer, den du in der Hinterhand hattest? Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Und es sind halt immer die gleichen Leute, die natürlich auch irgendwie immer genannt werden. Ich habe damals schon gesagt, als dann auch bei Daniel Scherning dann wieder die Kritik aufkam, wo ich mir so denke, ja, aber wer? Und die Hälfte sagt dann immer Bruno Labbadia, wo ich mir so denke, nicht ganz unser Preisregal, ich sage es, wie es ist, wäre nicht so das cleverste, davon habe ich gesehen, ob er zum Team passt. Das ist eine andere Frage. Aber es sind immer die gleichen fünf Namen in diesem Kreis. Als Erstes kommen immer Leute wie Florian Kohfeldt auf einmal wieder auf. Also irgendwelche Leute, die auch bei Bundesligavereinen nicht funktioniert haben, wo ich mir denke, ob die jetzt direkt in die zweite Liga gehen zu einem Abstiegskandidaten.
Ich finde aber auch gerade bei Abstiegskandidaten –Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich unterbreche –Ich finde gerade bei Abstiegskandidaten, egal welcher Liga, egal welcher Wettbewerb, finde ich das super, super schwierig zu sagen, wer tut sich das denn an quasi? Also in der Bundesliga der Frauen haben wir es zum Beispiel auch bei Turbine. Gut, da ist es eine ganz andere Geschichte nochmal, bei denen absolute Scheiße passiert. Entschuldigt bitte das Wort. Aber auch bei der Hertha, bei den Männern in der ersten Bundesliga, so Sachen, wo ich mich wirklich frage, wer tut sich das denn an? Und ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt –verzeiht mir das bitte wirklich –ich würde Regensburg da auf keinen Fall mit Turbine und der Hertha irgendwie auf einen Nenner stellen. Aber es sieht ja wirklich schon nicht gut aus. Und dieser Abstiegskampf in der zweiten Liga, der ist wahnsinnig eng, wahnsinnig hart. Das ist unglaublich schwierig da, sich irgendwie zu behaupten. Und wenn dann eben immer nur fünf gleiche Namen dabei sind, ist es schwierig, davon einen zu wählen. Aber noch schwieriger, vielleicht auch wirklich jemanden neuen zu holen, der sich das auch antut oder so. Also ich weiß es auch nicht. Naja, Ena, der eben, also wenn wir das jetzt nochmal abbinden, genau, wie es weitergeht am Wochenende gegen Karlsruhe, in Karlsruhe auch. Das Hinspiel hatten sie ja 0 zu 6 verloren. Da ist noch eine Rechnung offen. Dann geht es gegen Düsseldorf und dann nach Kiel. Und jetzt kommen wir zu dem nächsten Trainer, der jetzt neu mit dabei ist, Sandhausen. Die haben auch Alois Schwarz entlassen und jetzt Thomas Oral eingestellt. Die sind ganz gut, also mit dem ersten, also das erste Spiel im neuen Jahr war ganz gut, 2 zu 1 gegen Arminia eben gewonnen danach, aber gegen Darmstadt verloren, gegen Düsseldorf verloren, gegen Karlsruhe verloren, jeweils kein Tor geschossen. Und dazwischen lag auch noch eine Niederlage gegen Freiburg im DFB-Pokal, 0 zu 2. Und ich hab das Spiel getickert, es war so grauenvoll. Es war wirklich so ein grausames Spiel, sich das über 90 Minuten anzugucken, da ging quasi was gar nichts. Aber wie gesagt, seit vier Spielen wartet man auf ein eigenes Tor und auch logischerweise dann auf einen Sieg. Die Tamsen, Thomas Oral. Eva, du hast bei Twitter geschrieben, dass du das schon angekündigt hast, bevor die Pressemitteilung raus war. Oral war Co-Trainer unter Felix Maggert in Fulheim 2013-14, war auch beim FSV Frankfurt da auch sportlicher Leiter, war dann beim KSC bei Ingolstadt, wo er im Juni 2021 hier gegangen ist, war auch 2010-11 in Leipzig, als die noch Regionalliga gespielt haben. Also da auch so ein bisschen was von der Rabaschule mit abgegriffen. Eva, was erwartest du denn jetzt von Oral?
Ja, also man muss dazu sagen, das ist genau das, was ich meine. Man hat irgendwie über Nachfolger, wie als Bielefelder sagen, ich frage Kramer, Uli Forte, nimm die mal alle von unserem Ding. Und ich habe dann auch Spaß gehabt, ja, Thomas Oral gibt es ja auch noch, weil das ja immer der Klassikamoo von Ingolstadt irgendwann war. Ja, hier, wer immer auch gerade Trainer ist, der fliegt jetzt und wir holen Oral und dann in eine Relegation. Dann haben die halt den tatsächlich geholt. Und was, also wirklich, wenn ich als allererstes auf Ingolstadt gucke und auf das System, was Oral mit Ingolstadt gespielt hat, das war hauptsächlich ein 4-4-2. So, Sandhausen spielt eigentlich vor allem mit einer einsamen Spitze, wo ich auch sagen muss, da hat man jetzt Al-Gadoui geholt. Ich verstehe nicht, wer eine Doppelspitze bei Sandhausen stellen sollte, Nummer eins, davon eh abgesehen, dass sich ein Fokus absolut ins Mittelfeld und ins offensive Mittelfeld mit den Kids-Zombie-Brüdern legen würde, auch mit Spielern mit Aydini, mit Esfain. Ich sehe aber keine Doppelspitze bei Sandhausen. Ich sehe, dass man vor allem über das spielerische, es ist halt ein bisschen schwierig, also ohne da gemeint zu sein, aber es ist halt schwierig, da komplett auf spielerische zu gehen, aber durch spielerische im Mittelfeld zu gehen, dass es das für sich gut bespielen kann. Und ich weiß nicht, ob Oral, der auch bei Ingolstadt natürlich immer mit Spielern wie Kutke gearbeitet hat, ob das wirklich so der Weg ist. Ich weiß es nicht. Und gerade defensiv ist es halt auch wirklich nicht ansehnlich, was Sandhausen da zustande bringt. Die haben auch immer wieder viel mit Problemen, von Verletzungen zu kämpfen. Das ist auch wirklich nicht schön gewesen. Ich glaube, zwischendurch fünf Torhüter unter Vertrag, weil die ersten drei dann irgendwann verletzt waren. Dann hat man neun geholt, der hat sich dann auch direkt verletzt. Das spielt auch noch alles mit rein. Aber selbst absolute Leistungsträger in der Defensive wie einen Schirov, die mit defensiven Fehlern gegen Karlsruhe auftauchen, würde ich mir denken, okay. Gleichzeitig genau gleiches Spiel wie Nürnberg. Warum jetzt der Trainerwechsel? Was sollte Alui Schwarz in diesen ersten vier Spielen machen? Außer gegen Bielefeld gewinnen. We had this, it's not a big deal. So passiert vielen Vereinen in dieser Liga. Dann hattest du Darmstadt. Sorry, da erwartet ja sowieso niemand, dass du das gewinnst. Okay, wie du es verlierst, ist halt noch eine Sache. Das Düsseldorf-Spiel, gut, da hast du offensiv einfach nichts angeboten. Düsseldorf hat es dann irgendwann gemacht. Und dann Karlsruhe. Und jetzt hast du das Spiel gegen Nürnberg, wo du ganz genau weißt, dass du eigentlich gewinnen musst. Und dann holst du Thomas Oral. Mir fehlt da einfach ein bisschen die Fantasie. Wir haben über Kontinuität, wie wichtig es ist, dass Trainer in Transferphasen mit eingebunden werden. Du hattest jetzt die Möglichkeit, mit einer 2-monatigen Pause da irgendwas dran zu ändern. Und du hattest so einen Nee. Also, der hat jetzt zwar ein Spiel gewonnen. Also, das war es jetzt.
Das muss ich auch sagen, das ist wirklich merkwürdig. Sie haben ja in der Winterpause auch noch nachgelegt mit Fraunberger und Chadanoglu für die offensiven Außenverteidiger. Und da dachte ich mir auch so, okay, du nimmst quasi Diegmeier raus, ein Okorotschi raus, dafür holst du die zwei und setzt es erstmal ein. Dann hast du da jetzt eine Stellschraube gedreht, die sich mir nicht zwingend aufgetan hat. Dann holst du Al-Ghadaoui, Evina und noch den Bruder von unserem Melem. Und jetzt entlässt du einen Trainer. Das ist irgendwie merkwürdig. Und ich habe auch beim Kicker über eine Zahl gestolpert, in der aktuellen Ausgabe, dass die in den letzten 11 Spielzeiten 158 Spieler verpflichtet haben. Das ist ja unfassbar. So ein bisschen Kontinuität schreibt sich, glaube ich, anders. Und neue Bezen kehren gut, wenn es auf dem Spielfeld ist. Oftmals hat es irgendwie geklappt, aber jetzt hinterlässt es mich doch sehr ratlos. Und gerade dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt, das war für uns im Vorfeld im Podcast keinesfalls ausgemacht, dass wir da gewinnen. Weil wir wussten, gegen Bielefeld sind sie erst mal gut aus der Winterpause gekommen. Gegen Sandhausen kann man sich schon mal schwer tun, vor allem, wenn man sich an das Hinspiel erinnert hat. Da war mit Buchtmann und den Kindzombies einfach eine Körperlichkeit auf dem Platz, die schon wirklich à la bonheur sein kann. Und dann spielen wir da. Erster Standard, Kopfball-Tor. Kopfball durch Honsack, der ja auch erst frisch aus einer langen Verletzung kommt. Erster Startelf-Einsatz. Der macht danach noch gleich das 2-0, was von Tietz vorbereitet war, aber auch Haarsträuben in der Verteidigung. Und das Spiel war auch Deckel drauf. Und dann machen sie noch das 3-0 und das 4-0. Und so hätte ich Sandhausen nicht mir vorgestellt, dass die so das Spiel hinten runterkippen lassen. Und deshalb war für mich das im Vorfeld überhaupt nicht ausgemacht. Und dann, oh, das war ein leichter 3er. Also das war ja echt erstaunlich. Und das Stadion war auch so, Hälfte da am Start, Hälfte Sandhausen. Und da kam halt auch kein Impuls von Rängen. Also das ist eher so ein Publikum, da gibt es die Ultras hinter dem Block, aber dann ist es doch eher so ein bisschen, mal gucken, was geht. Und das sind jetzt keine guten Moves, die sich da jetzt oder Vibes bei mir auftun.
Nee, also vor allem das Ding ist ja gerade, weil Alois Schwarz auch damals für Koschinat geholt wurde, für die stabile Defensive. Und davon ist diese Saison für mich nicht übrig geblieben. Also sie haben zweimal gegen Bielefeld gewonnen, aber zweimal auch in einer Art und Weise, wo man wieder sagen muss, lag mehr am Gegner als an Sandhausen an sich. So da wieder ein Kind-Zombie-Moment. Es liegt definitiv dann nicht am Torhüter. Patrick Devis gehört für mich zu einem der besseren Torhüter der Liga. Es ist unfassbar unglücklich, dass er auch so verletzt war. Aber du hast auch mit Bachmann, was du angesprochen hast, einen Spieler, wo man drauf schauen kann. Aber sie haben halt auch einfach super viele Abgänge. Alleine letzte Saison hatten sie, glaube ich, zehn Winterabgänge und Neuzugänge. Also so etwas, wo andere Vereine sagen, ja, dann justieren wir mal ganz leicht nach. Ich meine, was sie bis jetzt nicht verkraftet haben, ist der erste Abgang von Pascal Testroth, der ja zur Ingolstadt gegangen ist. Dann hatte man Pull Krabb geholt, der diese Rolle überhaupt nicht füllen kann. Bei Al-Gadoui, ich denke mir halt, wenn ich dann irgendwann rausbekommen habe in der Saison, wir brauchen gar nicht diesen klassischen Stoßstürmer vorne drin, weil über die Standardstärke mit einem Okurochi kann ich auch einen Schirov und einen Bachmann darstellen. Und dann versuche ich aber auf Teufel, komme raus, wieder so einen Testroth reinzubringen mäßig und hole Al-Gadoui, gegen den ich persönlich nichts habe. Ich meine, der hat bei Stuttgart auch –also ich glaube, er ist ein ganz guter Zweitliga-Stürmer.
Er ist halt aber auch schon 32, ne?
Ja, und nochmal, eigentlich hast du ja was gefunden. Also du kannst eigentlich über die Außen –auch ich fand Gianna Lunu jetzt auch nicht schlecht. Ich finde auch einen Framberger, der kann sich gut auf der Seite durchsetzen. Aber ich glaube, diese Mannschaft weiß überhaupt nicht, was sie anstellen soll, wenn sie in den Strafraum kommt, weil die so oft den Fokus geschiftet haben diese Saison, wo ich mich frage, aber wer soll da denn auch stehen? Also es ist vollkommen egal, wer steht, weil irgendwie ist es auch überhaupt nicht klar, machen wir es jetzt über das Mittelfeld, machen wir es jetzt über die Außen. Es ist irgendwie ein Überangebot da, dafür, dass es keine Nachfrage für diese Bälle gibt.
Also auch da ein sehr großes Fragezeichen, wie das funktionieren soll, ne?
Ja, also du hast den Pulgrab, glaube ich, heißt er noch, der Tscheche, der hatte am zweiten Spieltag in Namtstadt auch seine erste Auswärtsfahrt in der zweiten Liga. Und der war für mich eher ein Leichtgewicht. Also der war deutlich abfallend von der Leistung. Und da dachte ich mir nachher noch so, da wird sie schon noch dran gewöhnen müssen, um Faktor zu sein, der im Moment gar nicht ist. Und so ähnlich war es bei uns in Namtstadt mit Warming und Wilhelmsson, zwei junge Skandinavier, die auch an Körperlichkeit noch zulegen müssen. Und die sind deutlich junger als Pulgrab. Also irgendwie dachte ich mir auch, ob der Transfer aufgeht und, naja, scheint sich so ein bisschen einzureihen in ein paar fragwürdigere Transfers.
Tanja, fällt dir noch was ein zu Sandhausen?
Ich finde es eigentlich sehr faszinierend, dass man mit dem Blick aus der ersten Liga, zum Beispiel, nennt man ja immer Sandhausen und Heidenheim in einem Atemzug sozusagen. Aber eigentlich sind das zwei völlig völlige Gegensätze. Weil du hast bei Heidenheim diese absolute Kontinuität, diesen absoluten Plan, wie sie spielen wollen und wie sie ihre Mannschaft zusammenstellen und mit Frank Schmidt diesen absoluten Anker. Während bei Sandhausen geht es wirklich kurvenweise auf und ab. Und mal haben sie wieder eine bisschen bessere Saison, wo sie auch mal ein bisschen oben mit anklopfen können. Aber dann geht es auch wieder gnadenlos runter in den Keller, wo sie dann wieder gegen den Abstieg spielen. Weil sie da auch diese Kontinuität, die du in der 2. Liga brauchst, nicht reinkriegen.
Machen wir mal einen Deckel drauf. Für Sandhausen geht es weiter am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg. Eben auch nach der Trainerentlassung, wie wir das ja schon gesagt hatten. Dann geht es gegen Kiel und dann gegen Lautern. Also alles nicht so einfache Partien. Und damit würde ich sagen, sind wir durch, oder? Habt ihr noch irgendwas, was euch auf dem Herzen liegt, was ihr unbedingt noch mitteilen wollt?
Vielleicht noch ein Fun-Fact zu Thorsten Lieberknecht bei den Ligien. Er ist jetzt seit insgesamt 55 Zweitligaspielen am Böllenfalltor. Ihr dürft mal raten, wie viele Punkte er da wohl ergattert, seither in 55 Spielen in der zweiten Liga. Ja, also es geht um die Punkte.
Okay, das würde nicht passen.
108 Punkte in 55 Zweitligaspielen, das bedeutet, 2-Punkte-Schnitt. Sorry, wenn ich hier gerade jemanden mit meiner Frage verwirrt habe. Also es ging um die Punkte in der zweiten Liga in 55 Spielen. 108 Punkte, das ist wirklich eine lange Distanz, ein 2er Schnitt. Und das ist schon krass, positiv krass.
Ich dachte, du willst jetzt so auf die 55-55-mäßig Prass zum Jubiläum.
Ja, aber das hätte auch irgendwie nicht gepasst. Wenn man länger drüber dachte, das wäre sehr wenig gewesen. Also wer drinnen im Abschließkart?
Wir haben letztes Jahr 7 Punkte geholt und davor haben wir einfach noch ein paar geschenkt bekommen.
Es ist ein 2-Stunden-Kurzpass.
Eben ein langen Pass quasi. Sorry dafür. Aber es hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Danke in die Runde. Ganz lieben Dank an euch fürs Zuhören und an euch fürs Dabeisein, an Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Podcast at Eva-Bohle auf Twitter, an Matthias Kneifl, Buchautor, Blogger, Podcaster, beim Ligien-Podcast Hoch und Weit, außerdem gelernter Historiker, auf Twitter zu finden, als Kick-Schuh-Blog. Und ganz lieben Dank auch an Tanja Hufschmidt vom HSV-Talk, manchmal auch bei frvzuhören.fschmidt77 auf Twitter. Schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart. Ganz lieben Dank.
Danke für die Einladung.
Danke dir für die Moderation.
Ja, ganz lieben Dank auf jeden Fall. Und auf ein gutes Topspiel am Samstagabend, würde ich mal sagen. Möge der bessere, möge das bessere Team gewinnen. Und an euch, Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr auch immer so lieb seid und mich auch so gut aufnehmt. Nächste Woche hört ihr wieder Max in der Schlusskonferenz mindestens. Und wenn ihr mehr von mir und zum Fußball der Frauen vielleicht auch hören wollt, ich meine, da gibt es natürlich auch immer Kurzpässe von Max dazu, die auch immer sehr, sehr höhrenswert sind, kann ich nur sehr empfehlen. Ich mache aber auch eben den Podcast die 45. Da spreche ich jede Woche mit Spielerinnen, aber eben auch mit so tollen Personen wie einer Tuber-Tackerl, die mit ihren Scoring Girls wirklich ganz, ganz tolle Dinge macht. Hört da sehr gerne mal rein. Und insgesamt kann ich auch noch sehr ans Herz legen, die Bundesliga der Frauen, auf jeden Fall sehens- und verfolgenswert. Ansonsten auch nochmal der Hinweis sehr gerne, registriert euch im supportersclub.rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Denkt dran, die Überweisungen anzupassen. Der Rasenfunk ist jetzt eine GmbH. Und lest unbedingt Maxbuch, falls ihr das noch nicht getan habt. Ansonsten tschüssi, ciao ciao, bis zum nächsten Mal.